my name is ola banji shonibar
i am an applied scientist at amazon i
work with the
pro language understanding service and
response team within alex's speech
my name is aparna and i'm a senior
applied scientist in the alexa speech
recognition team currently i'm working
on building better experiences for
bilingual customers of alexa just like
myself
my name is venky i'm an applied science
manager in alexa ai
me and my team of scientists work on
different parallel linguistic signals
associated with voice
as we know alexa is used by many
customers
across languages across age groups with
different types of voices
we make sure we understand everyone
irrespective of their variance in their
works
hey there and i'm lorenzo i'm an applied
science manager in the alexa test for
speech research team i joined the team
three years ago
with a task to improve the explosivity
and naturalness of our scientific voices
and this resulted in the release of the
emotional capabilities for alexa
currently i am working with many other
teams trying to push forward the
envelope of what we can do with our
technology
i'm kayoko i'm a senior speech scientist
in the texas beach team at amazon
i joined amazon five years ago and
initially worked on the launch of
amazon's first japanese text speech
voice
in the poly service followed by the
launch of the japanese alexa and more
recently
i've worked on the launch of bilingual
alexa making
the american english alexa voice speak
spanish
buenos dias migente
[Music]
i get to work on problems that are not
well defined you will be expected to
develop and deliver end-to-end solutions
you would work on problems that are on
structure
and then depending on the level you
might be expected to
mentor engineer colleague as well one of
the things that anyone will notice
when they work in alexa ai is the
amazing group of scientists
and engineers that we have around here
so there's lots to learn
over the last two years i've learned
quite a bit it's helped me
become a better scientist a better
thinker and a better employee
we are constantly learning new things we
are having to adapt and adopt new
technologies not only that we are
keeping learning we are keeping
absorbing technologies from other fields
such as nlp
or computer vision there is always a
chance to develop new things so i have
never bought many of the problems that i
worked on
did not have any prior research work on
it or very little of it there are also
problems on which there's plenty of
research available
but many times the work done on academic
data sets doesn't really translate
when we work on solving these problems
or alexa customers
i really enjoy the challenge of working
on and solving these problems
and this is really what makes innovation
at the heart of what we do at alexa
nowadays
more and more machine learning
techniques are being applied across
different domains and in texas speech
we're using a lot of approaches
developed outside
of the speech domain which means that we
see a lot of researchers with completely
different backgrounds
joining us in tts
the customers they are placed at the
forefront of every decision we make and
so
if there is any character or skill you
think
that would enable you to be customer
obsessed that's a plus one
alexa is a fantastic place for anyone
who wants to work on solving
real-world practical problems with deep
learning in the speech and natural
language understanding space
there's plenty of opportunity to
innovate and build state-of-the-art
solutions for some of these problems
you